i noticed at a certain point in your
life i think you were dating a certain
someone
but you dyed your hair brown and the
reason i bring it up is because when i
wanted to be taken seriously as an
actor i would dye my hair brown did you
ever feel that way
yeah i think i wanted to feel more
mature i wanted to take on
um a different sense of self
i wanted to look at myself a little bit
more
studious and like i mean i've even
i'm not doing that recently but like
even when
so when i gave up alcohol um the
funniest part was
we're all getting our hair colored and i
wanted it to be
bleach bleach blonde like and i was like
i want to look like andy warhol
and then i give up alcohol
you were like that was the alcohol talk
i was like you know what
i don't why would i want to look like
andy warhol i
i don't think that that's a normal thing
i don't think that that's
really who i am no that was that wasn't
my rock bottom but that definitely like
was a part of the day that i wish
i honestly had on video because it was
one of those moments where it was like
wow that moment of surrender was
beautiful well
i think that i'm so glad you are
i mean we have had a beautiful
voyeuristic
tender relationship with you for a long
time
and by the way everybody when i was
young at the mall
in waco texas
i would be asked weekly for
my autograph because everybody thought i
was the girl from e.t
oh my god like it's like
we do look a lot alike as kids and i'm
wondering if it made me want to be in
the entertainment business and now that
i
sit here and think about it
subconsciously uh that's very possible
i have a picture of us at the super bowl
back in the day it's so fun
and i just remember that day being such
a blast
i love that i know it was a good day but
i um i was reading uh you recently
opened up an
amazon original essay called take the
lead and i read it
backwards and forwards and it's just
beautiful and one thing
that i would love to ask you before we
wrap up
because there was something that really
really hit me
about it through circumstances in your
life with your cousin
that you felt like if you put it all out
there
that it might be the end you might die
may ask why you thought that
um well my
best friend and cousin was killed
at the age of 17 and i was
a couple years younger than her so it
was a very traumatic thing that
that i went through and she was killed
by a horse
jumping through the windshield of a
pickup truck and
um and my dad did
um her funeral and he used all of
her journal entries which i didn't even
know that she kept
and the things that she wrote like they
give you chills
and it was almost like as if she knew
that
these were her final days like the very
last thing she wrote in her
journal was when i die i'll graduate and
it was a week before graduation
i think because of the trauma um
i started journaling and i wanted people
to know how much i loved
them and how much i prayed for them and
i truly thought that when i released the
memoir
those were going to be words that would
be left behind
i didn't know that it would be when i
was you know walking through life with
a lot more of it to live um but
i had just had a feeling like but
and and i just think that once i
like rewired my subconscious mind
and let go of that trauma and face some
fears that my daughter
actually encouraged me to face and that
was being with
a horse and um
like and maxwell encouraged me to throw
my fear over the mountain
and to scream it over the mountain and
so i don't think that any of us are
going anywhere anytime soon i mean i
might be riding on a horse around here
in hidden hills but that's about it
well cherries are not coming yet i thank
you for facing those fears because
may you live the most open book life the
most free
well we cannot wait for your amazon
specials
and particularly your amazon original
essay
uh take the lead that i've read it's so
beautiful
and open book just came out in paperback
and
it's the number one bestseller and i
thank you
for sharing your life with us and
i just think you're such a dynamic
dichotomy of a woman and
we're all celebrating you so thank you
i'm like the star struck and turning red
you're making me
like that's what i want yeah
thank you jessica simpson for your time
thank you truly
you